[Music]
after the musical Hamilton became a
Broadway sensation and won every award
from the Tony to the Pulitzer Prize
creator lin-manuel Miranda decided to
hang up his costume and leave the lead
role to others but last night Miranda
was back in that colonial garb and back
on stage for the opening of a very
special run of the show David beg no
joins us now from San Juan Puerto Rico
with that story what an incredible
opportunity David tell us all about it
Michelle have you have you seen the
musical Oh twice oh my gosh well I have
to tell you I had not it was my first
time seeing it in Puerto Rico and that
was intentional I wanted to seal in on
this stage on this island give it
everything that's happened right since
Hurricane Maria and the history of the
island with poverty and austerity and
beauty and beaches I got to tell you
when lin-manuel walked on that stage the
first words out of his mouth are
Alexander Hamilton they lost it I mean
for like 30 seconds and you could see
you could see the emotion on his face
history had its eyes on Puerto Rico last
night lin-manuel Miranda overwhelmed as
the sold-out crowd of 1800 continued to
erupt in applause Miranda a favorite son
of Puerto Rico returned to the stage
reprising the lead role in his musical
creation Hamilton in San Juan the
original venue was changed in December
over security concerns he gave his
father much of the praise
[Applause]
[Applause]
this madness and of course doom ideas on
after the show Miranda put it all in
perspective I just love this island so
much and I just wanted to be proud of me
the 38 year old has taken the lead on
raising funds to help restore the arts
ravaged by debt and the cost of
rebuilding after Hurricane Maria lucky
fans arrived hours before show time
tickets go for as much as $5,000 but
every Wednesday there's a matinee
performance where tickets are $10 each
actor Ronald Weber jr. plays Aaron Burr
opposite Miranda it's more than just an
opening it's more than just another show
another opening another show it's like
the way that we're supposed to be it's
what theatre supposed to do we're
supposed to encourage uplift and make a
difference and that's what it feels like
we're doing here Thursday night at the
final dress rehearsal
Miranda received a 21 second applause
when he stepped onstage this applause
was so significantly different and
electric because it was a homecoming a
homecoming that Miranda and his fellow
Puerto Ricans can raise a glass to
and now that Lynne has come home by the
way he used to spend summers here with
his grandparents he brought everybody he
brought extended family I mean there are
dozens of miranda's running around the
island right now and a lot of them are
gonna stay here Dana for the whole
three-week run I don't want a great
celebration of the oh no doubt David and
I love that he was talking about his kid
watching him in the show and having to
explain it David great work down there
thank you so much for bringing it to us